foreign
we've been watching this story all
weekend with growing bewilderment last
Friday morning as you know around 2 A.M
police arrived at the home of the
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi it's
in the Pacific Heights neighborhood of
San Francisco inside the home they found
Pelosi's 82 year old husband Paul and
another man 40 years younger called
David de Papi it's supposed to was out
of town at the time in full view of the
police to Papi hit Paul Pelosi in the
head two times with a hammer both Pelosi
and de Papi were then taken immediately
to a local hospital Pelosi for his head
injuries and to Papi for reasons that
are still not clear to Papi was later
charged in federal court with assault
and attempted kidnapping at this point
that's what we can say for certain David
de Papi assaulted Paul Pelosi with a
hammer apparently de Papi has admitted
that in police custody but beyond those
facts there is much in the story that
remains muddy how for example did the
Papi get inside the Pelosi's home that's
the first question last year ABC News
reported which you already guessed which
is that Pelosi has round-the-clock
protection at her houses quote she has
her own security she has the Capitol
Police they fly all the way out here
from Washington D.C with her
and yet in this case San Francisco D.A
Brook Jenkins says that there was no
security present at the Pelosi home on
Friday night
and that's pretty strange because
according to multiple accounts even when
Pelosi isn't at home her houses are well
guarded again as you would expect our
friend harmeet Dylan told us that when
her firm recently tried to serve a
lawsuit against Paul Pelosi at various
properties he owns all of them were
guarded by quote multiple law
enforcement officers on the perimeter
so how did Papi get past security that
apparently wasn't there and why wasn't
it there if in fact it wasn't
we know he got inside and once he was
inside what exactly happened next
well accounts of that are changing at
the first press conference on Friday San
Francisco police suggested there was a
third person in the home when police
arrived and Politico dutifully reported
that quote officers arrived at the house
knocked on the front door and were LED
Inside by an unknown person in other
words by a person who was not David de
Papi or Paul Pelosi now political never
formally corrected this claim instead
just two days later Politico the same
publication attacked anyone who repeated
its own reporting as it crazed
conspiracy Monger quote pro-trump
commentators weighed in online to raise
questions about the investigation based
on unfounded and false claims among
those baseless claims that a third
person answered the door when police
arrived at the Pelosi home
okay three separate adjectives knocking
down that idea but the question remains
was there a third person at the home we
don't know but it's not crazy to assume
there was here's how today's charging
documents describe the scene inside the
house quote when the door was opened
Pelosi and de Papi were both holding a
hammer with one hand and de Papi had his
other hand holding on to Pelosi's
forearm Pelosi greeted the officers the
officers asked them what was going on
the Papi responded everything was good
so it's an awful scene in some ways but
here's the critical Clause when the door
was opened well opened by whom
Common Sense suggests it probably
couldn't have been Pelosi or de Papi who
opened it they were locked in a life or
death drama a struggle over a hammer
the documents filed today assert that
Paul Pelosi had never seen David de Papi
before yet in Pelosi's
911's first name and apparently referred
to him as a friend
here's the audio this is from a
dispatcher relaying Paul Pelosi's call
RV stated that there's a male in the
home and that he's going to wait for his
wife however he's saying that he doesn't
know who the male is but he advised that
his name is David and that he is a
friend
so what does that mean exactly well
again we don't know and we can't know we
do know that anyone who's ever met Paul
Pelosi can tell you he is an awfully
nice man he's warm and he's friendly and
he certainly didn't deserve to be hit in
the head with a hammer it's horrifying
that he was
but as long as this is a news story with
public policy implications and
unfortunately that's what it's become it
is fair to ask the obvious questions as
you would about any other violent crime
that occurs in America and especially
this one since so many facts basic facts
seem to be in dispute local KTVU
investigative reporter Evan cernofsky
for example initially reported that the
Papi was quote found in underwear when
police arrived today sarnovsky made a
specific point of retracting that claim
quote I'm now told by other sources that
the Papi was not dressed only in his
underwear
well okay fair enough we'd be satisfied
with either explanation not really our
business
but you can't blame and this is the
point you can't blame people watching
all of this at home for thinking that
maybe there's something weird going on
here parts of the official account don't
seem to make any sense so the solution
obviously is to release the police body
cam footage from last Friday that's
often done immediately in cases like
this cases that attract heavy Punk
scrutiny transparency restores The
public's faith in the system it is the
only thing that does in fact that's the
whole point of body cams to reassure
people that they can really know what
happened
transparency is the antidote to quote
misinformation
on the other hand if you want people to
fall head first into crazed conspiracy
theories then you would keep lying and
hiding things
and yet for some reason the San
Francisco police department is refusing
to release Friday's body cam video we
learned that today when we filed a
records request no chance they said
so until we see that tape there is a lot
that we cannot know
but the main question tonight the one
that's going to affect your life going
forward because this story will affect
your life the question is who exactly is
David de Papi
many in the media seem studiously
uninterested they don't really want to
know at a police press conference last
week a reporter was caught on a hot mic
being instructed by someone not to
discuss to Papi in any great detail
so it was left in the end to a
journalist who doesn't work for a big
media Outlet independent reporter
Michael schellenberger to fill in some
of the blanks schellenberger first did
the obvious he went to where the Papi
was living across the bay in Berkeley
you're seeing an image of it on your
screen right now apparently de Pappy was
camping full-time in a dilapidated Ken
keezy style School Bus complete with a
gay pride flag out front and a sign that
reads Berkeley stands against hate
behind the bus hangs a BLM Banner
so politically this picture could not be
clear you know where this guy stands but
shellenberger and others kept digging
they found that the Papi was in fact
well known in the area in the entire Bay
Area as a hallucinogenic drug Enthusiast
and a semi-professional nudist he often
appeared at nudist theme events
does David de Papi have a prior criminal
history that's an obvious question
perhaps a relevant one but we can't
answer it because once again authorities
in San Francisco have refused to tell us
or anyone else
we do know that the people around it
David de Papi believed that he was
completely deranged the ones who knew
him best thought that the San Francisco
Chronicle interviewed his ex-girlfriend
who reported that the Papi is mentally
ill and struggles with drugs for example
he once thought he was quote Jesus for a
year he's never been able to hold a job
said the former girlfriend he has been
homeless this person really does suffer
from mental illness and that is probably
why he was there at 2 am she described
him as a quote broken child in an adult
body with serious mental problems
to Pappy's neighbors Who would know said
more or less the same thing
anything strange about him or anything
that stood up there's something strange
about the whole household the entire
household is very very strange how about
him
um uh he is birds of a feather with a
Akin to them so they are just you know
nudist drug abusers and that's who
gravitates toward them
so just another homeless mentally ill
drug addict with the fondness for BLM
that's not quite so unusual in San
Francisco oh and there's one other
highly unsurprising thing about David de
Papi he's also an illegal alien today
Fox's Bill malugin learned that to Papi
who was originally from Canada has long
overstayed his Visa so he is currently
in this country illegally
so to restate the perpetrator in this
violent crime against Paul Pelosi is a
mentally ill drug addicted illegal alien
nudist who takes hallucinogens and lives
in a hippie school bus in Berkeley with
a BLM banner and a pride flag out front
so take those uncontested facts and let
them rattle around your brain for a
moment until a recognizable pattern
emerges
what does this sound like to you if you
guessed this is obviously a textbook
case of homegrown right-wing extremism
well then obviously you've been watching
a lot of cable news today here's a
selection
is this political violence in your
opinion
it seems to be clear uh that the
the content of his social media and the
statements he allegedly made about
where's Nancy we're going to wait for
Nancy uh certainly points in that
direction seems like
it's like home and prioritize
um there are feelings this is about
election denialism what has happened
over the last two years has seeped into
uh the minds and the thoughts of some
unstable people deranged right wing
Fanatics Trump media allies and some of
the most powerful people in the world
were feverishly trying to stir up
conspiracy theories that distracted from
the central political headline of this
story
that years of Republican propaganda and
Trump fueled fascism LED 42-year-old
David depap to break into Nancy Pelosi's
San Francisco home
well to be fair the fact that Mika
Brzezinski has a high-paying job does
give rise to conspiracy theories I mean
in a fair Society how could that happen
but it has but the bottom line is ladies
and gentlemen the mentally ill homeless
illegal alien drug addict who lives in a
painted school bus in Berkeley with the
BLM flag is actually despite all
appearances another member of Donald
Trump's Q Anon Army
is CNN commentator David Axelrod put it
far-right conspiracy theories are to
blame here then of course Jen Rubin at
the Washington Post accused right-wing
Republicans of inciting violence against
the Pelosi family using this illegal
alien homeless guy on drugs
the far right demonized Pelosi and that
led to the attack read a banner on MSNBC
so on what grounds other than political
desperation are they saying things like
this well according to some reports the
homeless mentally ill drug addicted
illegal alien David to Papi somehow
maintained websites with right-wing
content on them one of these sites was
apparently called friendlyfriends.com
and the strange thing about that website
is that the web address for it was
registered back in September but there's
content on the site that is backdated to
August
an internet archiving Services didn't
register any content from that blog
apparently David de Pappy's blog until
October 28th that was the day of De
Pappy's attack on Paul Pelosi on October
28th friendlyfriends.com suddenly
included a bunch of incoherent posts
about UFOs and Peter Navarro
I'm not making that up those are the
facts what do they mean well it's a
right-wing conspiracy obviously better
indict Marjorie Taylor green for the
crime
so keep in mind as you shake your head
in bewilderment at all of this that the
midterm elections are next Tuesday and
Democrats are in trouble and they
believe the attack on Paul Pelosi might
help them as Margaret Brennan explained
over on CBS because a mentally ill
illegal alien attacked Nancy Pelosi's
husband is now immoral to criticize the
leader of Democrats a week before an
election Savor this
Republican candidates have spent more
than 116 million on ads that mentioned
speaker Pelosi by name in this cycle
if this is about the issues
why don't you make it about the issue
out don't you think this needs to change
why not pull some of these what are you
making about this about these shoes said
the lady who spent four years screaming
about Donald Trump the man
it's hilarious and Brazen and Shameless
and the second the midterms are over
they'll stop but the point is as always
all the journalists journalists got the
same memo and they're all running with
the same memo of course using exactly
the same words Ashley Parker at the
Washington Post wrote this quote in 2022
the GOP spent 40 million dollars
vilifying pelosian ads and on Friday her
husband was attacked by a hammer do you
see the direct correlation if you
criticize Nancy Pelosi obviously you're
endangering her family of course she
does run the political party
that's facing re-election right now that
controls the United States Congress he's
third in line for the presidency but you
can't criticize her because if you do
you're just like your acolyte Paul De
Papi
so the Republican Party clearly needs to
stop running advertisements that hurt
Democrats ahead of the midterms please
that's the problem here not the mentally
ill BLM nudist in Berkeley
so what they're really arguing is in the
wake of this attack which is awful
against someone who did not deserve it
and we want to be clear about that
publicity really is a nice guy hard to
believe but he is but in the wake of
that they're telling you unfortunately
you can no longer have free speech well
you can't
they're telling you this is an example
of stochastic terrorism which is a
completely meaningless phrase that
emerged like a virus out of the
university to infect our public
discourse or more precisely to suppress
our public discourse Reuters has
reported that we're quoting terrorism
and extremism experts believe it could
be an example of the growing threat of
so-called stochastic terrorism in which
sometimes unstable individuals are
inspired to Violence by hate speech
okay what is hate speech by the way all
of a sudden everyone in the media has
sort of without explaining why agreed
that there's this thing called hate
speech that's real and probably
actionable
they can find a billion dollar judgment
against you if you commit hate speech
but just to remind everyone watching
there's no such thing as hate speech
hate speech is speech people hate
usually the people in power the truth is
all speech except speech that encourages
people to imminent illegal action like
go shoot that guy short of that there's
no hate speech all of it's allowed under
the United States Constitution
which is our final hope
but what they're telling you is that
dissenting in any way from the editorial
positions of say the Washington Post or
The Daily Beast or the Atlantic magazine
disagreeing with those Publications and
the consensus they represent isn't
simply immoral no it's worse than that
it's violence it gets people killed
that's the stochastic terrorism when you
question say covet protocols or drag
queen Story Hour or the war against
Russia you are effectively smashing an
82 year old man in the head with a
hammer
they're making that argument and of
course they have no choice but to make
that argument Democrats are very worried
about the coming elections but they're
absolutely terrified that Elon Musk may
allow people to criticize them on
Twitter
and they know what Republicans don't
seem to know which is without censorship
the Democratic party cannot continue to
hold power Democrats understand that
they have nothing to offer they have to
stop you from asking questions
so they have to crush Elon Musk not
because he's a right winger but because
he will allow their opponents to speak
and of course they are using the attack
on poor Paul Pelosi to do just that the
New York Times has just come out with a
piece that says and we're quoting Elon
Musk in a tweet shares a link from a
site known to publish fake news
really what did Elon Musk do well he
linked to an article about how Paul
Pelosi called the guy in his home a
friend
well that's what the 911 tape says you
can draw your own conclusions or not or
maybe you don't care which is also fine
how is that fake seems to be real NBC
news's Ben Collins explained that musk's
tweets are quote how you lose a
democracy in the age of the internet Oh
by asking questions Jimmy Kimmel
attacked musk personally used to be a
comic sad to watch that decline it's
been interesting Kimmel wrote to us to
watch you Blossom for the electric car
guy into a fully formed piece of human
excrement
that CNN told its viewers today that in
the wake of the attack on Paul Pelosi
Elon Musk can no longer let people speak
freely on Twitter that was his plan but
no more in the wake of the attack on
Pelosi musk must retain quote what the
far right calls censorship well the far
right
but you don't need to be far right to
identify it as censorship because
censorship is exactly what it is and to
restate Democrats could no longer exist
or hold power without it they need
censorship and they're going to try to
use this horrifying crime
to hold on to it but something else is
going on here too something beneath even
all of that
obviously by immediately politicizing
the attacks Democrats get a lot
potentially but the main thing they do
is effectively obscure the deepest truth
of all which is that what happened to
Paul Pelosi is not so unusual anymore
crime in this country is out of control
by every measure attacks by the mentally
ill homeless
even non-nudists who don't live in buses
but the mentally ill homeless are not
their own category they're a feature of
life in our cities in fact if every part
of this country controlled by the
Democratic party if you live in one of
those places no matter who you vote for
you know that that's true
get pushed in front of a subway train by
one of them that's entirely real
here's one recent and especially awful
example from California a 54 year old
man and his 22 year old daughter were
just stabbed to death in the parking lot
of a Kohl's in Palmdale by a mentally a
homeless man
not an unusual story but a particularly
awful one here's a local news account
residents say there are multiple
homeless encampments in the area and
that people are known to live out of
their cars in the back of this
particular parking lot everyone said
they're shocked by the violence for me I
was like dumbfounded this thing like
wait somebody's got stabbed in raw
daylight I mean like again it doesn't
matter if it's daylight or nighttime but
the fact that people have the audacity
which means hey people don't care you
know especially when you're dealing with
the type of mentalities that these
homeless people have they don't care so
to find out like wait a minute somewhere
where I go and Shop to get gas and my
bank is right here but then some dead
person is right there
that's infuriating and sad
so to restate with heartfelt sincerity
we couldn't feel worse about what
happened to Paul Pelosi he didn't
deserve it
on the other hand if you're going to be
injured in a violent crime in 2022
not so surprising that that crime was
committed by a mentally ill homeless man
because so many crimes are committed by
mentally ill homeless people a fact that
everyone who lives in a city understands
perfectly well and the people who are
making it possible the leaders of the
democratic party assiduously ignore
this summer a non-profit director in San
Francisco for example a man called James
spignola asked two homeless men to move
away from the steps of a community
center in response the homeless men's
violently beat him with a wooden plank
and sent him to the hospital this
happened at 11 A.M in broad daylight
this happens all the time and here's the
point the psycho drug adult zombies who
do it are usually released the same day
to do it again everyone knows that it's
not an accident as a result of policy
policies that Nancy Pelosi supports in
her own City
but in this case the guy did not walk
because it happened at Nancy Pelosi's
house so the guy is still in jail he's
not benefiting from cashless bail the
police got there in two minutes in San
Francisco
that's four times faster than the
average average response time in San
Francisco
four times
so the lesson here couldn't be more
obvious and their screaming is designed
to keep you from reaching this
conclusion but here it is Nancy Pelosi
and her party the Democratic party is
not an overstatement to say this have
deliberately created a breakdown in Law
and Order and safety and quality of life
in your neighborhood yet they are given
special treatment themselves when it
happens to them
so you can grieve the attack on Paul
Pelosi and see it as horrifying because
it is and still understand that the
response to it would not be extended to
you it's a double standard it's a
two-tiered system of justice that's
completely unacceptable and it's not
Justice in fact
it's the opposite
so the media ought to be saying
something about this this is happening
this crime specifically happened but so
many others have happened because of
policies designed to allow them to
happen
and someone on the Press should point
that out hey Paul Pelosi's not the only
guy who got attacked by a nutcase
homeless guy this month but they're not
saying that and because they're not
saying that Democratic politicians get
to skate and not just skate but to
grandstand on Republican violence
in ways that any person with a sense of
Shame would be
totally incapable of doing
because you'd hate yourself for doing it
but they don't hate themselves they'll
say whatever it takes on the very same
day that Barack Obama blamed Republicans
for assaulting Paul Pelosi
Obama was campaigning in Wisconsin for
Tony Evers does that name sound familiar
that's the governor who led homicidal
mobs take over the city of Kenosha two
years ago for political reasons watch
this
we've got politicians
who work to stir up division
to try to make us angry and afraid of
one another
for their own advantage
and all of it gets amped up hyped up 24
7 by social media
because a lot of times those are they're
four profit platforms and they find it
more profitable
to feed you controversy and conflict
instead of facts and Truth
and and and sometimes it it can turn
dangerous
oh your speech turns dangerous other
people are stirring up resentment really
no president American history ever
caused intentionally caused more racial
division more race hate than Barack
Obama did of course was the key to a
second term obviously but the solution
to something that he did
is prohibiting you from saying what you
think
shutting down your constitutionally
protected right your god-given right to
say what you think is true is always the
solution because they conflate words
with violence when it suits them
in Georgia last week Barack Obama said
Democrats the party that defunded the
police the Democratic party somehow he
said Bears no responsibility for the
rise and violent crime all over the
country in fact Obama pretended
Democrats had not voted to defund the
police at all who actually voted against
more resources for the police
departments yes it's like if you'll say
anything maybe it works
yeah whoever sees Baltimore and Gary
Indiana and Minneapolis and New York and
Seattle and Portland Oregon how are
those cities doing
speaking of shamelessness Kathy hokel
just went on Al Sharpton show to claim
that the crime wave the one that you're
watching the one that may have hurt you
or killed one of your neighbors it's all
fake
in a statement that is crazier than
anything Alex Jones has ever thought
they have this accuracy going all across
America to try and convince people that
in Democratic states are not as safe
well guess what they're also not only
election deniers they're data deniers
the data shows that shootings and
murders are down in our state by 15
percent even in New York City down 20
percent on Long Island really zeldin
comes from
so that's just a lie actually New York
is so dangerous that people are leaving
rents haven't gone down because foreign
investors are buying up a lot of the
buildings but people are leaving New
York in droves of course but according
to Kathy hokel in a claim that is truly
crazier than anything Alex Jones has
ever even thought in the shower to
himself Kathy hokel is telling you
that the data are fake
so here you have a city in which New
York City subway ridership has dropped
by 40 percent over the last two years
now according Kathy hopeless not because
Subway Riders are being pushed in front
of trains people being attacked by
mentally homeless no it's because
apparently millions of New Yorkers are
watching Fox news they've been fooled by
right-wing propaganda into thinking the
subway is dangerous
that's what she's suggesting
this is too stupid this is a lie voters
know it's a lie and when Democrats get
crushed in next week's midterms it'll be
in part because people who live in
cities and states run by liberals
understand that what happened to Paul
Pelosi could very well happen to them
and no one would care
Morning Joe had pretend it never
happened subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight